das ist der Stoff aus dem die Welt
Hoffnung schöpft um die Pandemie zu
beenden und Menschenleben zu retten
der covid 19 Impfstoff offiziell
gehandelt nur zwischen Herstellern und
Regierungen doch dazwischen scheinen
sich unzählige Geschäftemacher zu
tummeln die mit der heißen Ware das
große Geld machen wollen das ist ein
bisschen wie Goldgräberstimmung ein
Luxushotel in Stuttgart hier treffen wir
einen Zwischenhändler mit versteckter
Kamera wir geben uns selbst als Händler
für Medizinprodukte und Impfstoffe aus
und haben uns mit ihm verabredet
ich habe vor zwei Monaten eine Order der
Dominikanischen Republik für eine
Million astra-senica eingereicht die
haben schon damals gesagt bis April
müssen Sie warten jetzt kommen sie eine
Million für die Dominikanische Republik
wilde in Astra Seneca dass das alles ein
bisschen leiser passiert
komplett
weil die die Öffentlichkeit da nicht
drin haben wollen genau
ein heimlicher Handel mit Impfstoff
unser Gesprächspartner ist Dr o ein
Stuttgarter Arzt
[Musik]
dr OL liefert uns Belege sogenannte
letters of Intent von Staaten die bei
ihm Impfstoff Anfragen selbst ameländer
sind bereit bis zum 16-fachen dessen zu
bezahlen was die EU hinlegt so groß ist
die Not frontan21 liegen von Dr obe
Stellungen und Anfragen aus aller Welt
vor Libyen will 6 Millionen Dosen
die Dominikanische Republik eine Million
Barbados 600.000 Dosen
Bosnien-Herzegowina 500.000
doch wie will die beschaffen wir suchen
den Sitz seiner Firma in der Schweiz auf
doch dort finden wir nicht mehr als
einen handbeschrifteten Briefkasten
ist das seriös
zurück in Stuttgart finden wir einen der
DR o Kent und das Geschäft
auch Anton Marino handelt mit
Medizinprodukten und will jetzt beim
Impfstoff mitmischen kann Marine uns
erklären wo die Ware herkommen soll wo
doch Europa seit Monaten auf Lieferungen
wartet
wenn wir jetzt auch die Meldungen immer
wieder kriegen Astra Seneca liefert
deutlich weniger als zugesagt war bei
Problemen in den Berg gibt was sagt mir
das du sagt mir dass die Abzweige um
einfach mit der anderen Menge wo sie
abgezweigt haben mehr Geld zu verdienen
weil wir immer wieder Nachfragen liefert
Doktor o und immer mehr Dokumente
auch aus dem EU-Mitgliedsland Italien
mindestens vier Millionen Dosen
wir fahren nach Italien
mehrere Regionalregierungen haben über
Doktor o-anfragen gestellt
in Umbrien ermittelt die
Staatsanwaltschaft nachdem sich ein Mann
der Impfstoff an bot als Astra sinniker
Manager ausgab per Skype erreichen wir
den Staatsanwalt der bei den
impfstoffhändlern von einem
internationalen Netzwerk ausgeht
zuerst haben wir überprüft ob diese
Person die Impfstoffe angeboten hat ein
Betrüger ist heute erscheint es uns
plausibler dass er wir behauptet keinen
Schwindler ist sondern dass es in seinem
Umfeld Leute gibt die tatsächlich über
Impfstoffe verfügen
der Mann den der Staatsanwalt vernommen
hat entpuppt sich als Mitarbeiter einer
Schweizer Firma von Dr o
bei unserem versteckt gefilmten treffen
wollen wir genauer herausfinden wie die
Geschäfte abgewickelt werden
das ganze läuft über Vertriebspartner
der Hersteller ich arbeite mit aircas
Nano technology zusammen die sind
offizieller Partner von Astra Seneca
würde den Astra sinniker uns bestätigen
dass Lakers ihr Partner ist
es gibt keine Verträge Ackers nennt eine
Astra Managerin in Texas die muss man
mal erreichen
wir machen uns auf den Weg nach Texas in
die USA
und versuchen dort die Managerin
ausfindig zu machen
tatsächlich bietet die Firma Ackers
nanotechnology die Impfstoffe von Astra
Seneca und biontech offen zum Kauf an
aber können die echt sein
schriftlich verweist Akas auf die
besagte Mitarbeiterin von Astra Seneca
in den USA Whitney m
wir versuchen Whitney m zu erreichen
doch sie antwortet nicht zu Hause
treffen wir lediglich ihren Ehemann an
sie sei nicht da
schließlich erreichen wir sie doch
telefonisch aber kein Kommentar
derweil erklärt uns der Konzern
astroseniker schriftlich es gäbe derzeit
Zitat keine Lieferung keinen Verkauf
oder Vertrieb des Impfstoffs durch den
privaten Sektor wenn jemand private
Impfstoffe anbietet handelt es sich
wahrscheinlich um Fälschungen
was sagt pharma-händler Ackers dazu die
Firma sitzen in der Nähe von
Philadelphia den vorwurfälschungen zu
verkaufen beißt sie weit von sich man
habe als Großhändler eine offizielle
Lizenz Impfstoffe weiter zu verkaufen
Zitat
Akers nanotechnology hat als
Vertriebspartner Beziehungen zu vielen
Unternehmen inklusive Astra Seneca wir
verhandeln derzeit mit allen
potenziellen Herstellern über
mengenpreise und Lieferdaten für deren
kovit 19 Impfstoffe
seit Monaten wartet die EU auf
impfstofflieferungen insbesondere von
Astra Seneca der Konzern kommt seinen
vertraglichen Verpflichtungen nicht nach
was wenn es stimmt das Vertriebspartner
die Ware derweil weltweit verkaufen
können
[Musik]
Astra Seneca muss dringend aufklären was
es damit zu tun hat dass offensichtlich
neben den Lieferverpflichtungen
verschiedenen Ländern in der Welt
Parallelstrukturen von parallelmärkten
beliefert werden auch mit dem Ziel dass
dort Menschen versuchen an dem Leid an
der Not anderer Geld zu verdienen
noch einmal nach Stuttgart wir wollen
herausfinden ob dieser Vorwurf nur
AstraZeneca betrifft
und gegenüber spricht dr o im
Stuttgarter Hotel auch von anderen
Herstellern
die slowakische Regierung hat auch
schriftlich bestellt eine Million Dosen
von biontech Pfizer aber die Slowakei
ist doch EU-Mitglied warum machen die
das an der EU vorbei
weil sie sonst gar nichts kriegen
laut Dokumenten von Dr o hat das
eu-mitgliedslowakei eine Million
dosenbaiontech Impfstoff bestellt wir
fahren nach Bratislava
die Infektionszahlen dort rasten im
Frühjahr in die Höhe das
Gesundheitsministerium hat sich deshalb
nach Alternativen umgeschaut um an mehr
Impfstoff zu kommen als die EU
beschaffen konnte
die Lieferungen über die EU haben sich
immer wieder verzögert deshalb haben wir
nach Wegen gesucht um möglichst schnell
weitere sichere Impfstoffe in unser Land
zu bekommen um das Tempo der Impfungen
zu erhöhen
liefern soll die deutsche Firma CS
diagnostics in Neuss sie ist ein Partner
von Dr o der preisprothose biontech
liegt wieder weit über dem was die EU
mit dem Hersteller verhandelt hat auf
Nachfrage lässt uns das Unternehmen über
einen Anwalt mitteilen Zitat in der
Verkauf des biontech-impfstoffs ist
legal unsere Mandantschaft kauft den
Impfstoff direkt beim Hersteller also
bei biontech Pfizer oder bei vom
Hersteller offiziell autorisierten
Vertretern
kann es legal sein dass biontech seinen
Impfstoff über Zwischenhändler verkauft
auf unsere Bitte umstellungnahme
erhalten wir von dem Mainzer Unternehmen
keine Antwort
was sagt die Bundesregierung dazu dass
mit heiß begehrten Impfstoffen
Zwischenhändler gute Geschäfte machen
wollen
ist Ihnen das bekannt und wenn ja was
sagen sie dazu gerade im Fall Astra
Seneca der Hersteller kommt ja dann
vertraglichen Verpflichtungen gegenüber
Deutschland bisher nicht nach also wir
erhalten tatsächlich eigentlich zu allen
Impfstoffen die es auf der Welt gibt
entsprechende Angebote von
Zwischenhändlern das ist ein bisschen
wie eigentlich in dieser Pandemie immer
wieder mit verschiedenen Produkten es
entsteht dann so eine Goldgräberstimmung
an verschiedenen Bereichen und dann wird
versucht mit Angeboten aller Art was zu
machen wir als Bund jedenfalls
beschaffen bei den Herstellern wenn der
Impfstoff hier an den Verträgen
vorbeigeliefert wird und wir bekommen
nicht unsere Kontingente dann ist das
schlichtenergreifend Vertragsbruch und
also grenzt an einen
Wirtschaftsverbrechen das hat er so aus
meiner Sicht nichts mit der typischen
Goldgräberstimmung zu tun
Goldgräberstimmung auf diesen Dosen ruht
die Hoffnung der ganzen Welt gerade
jetzt in der dritten Welle im Wettlauf
um leben sind tot versuchen Länder
möglichst viel für sich rauszuholen ob
das auch für die Impfstoffhersteller
gilt müssen die schnell aufklären